alright now I'm going to employ them up
here okay because remember what I want
is not like the gradient here what does
that to do this I want dy DX right dy DX
and I have this pesky theta kind of
hanging around in the middle all right
so what piece of information am I going
to use that can connect a derivative of
this and drew this to a derivative of
this two words chain rule I market our
dy/dx right I'm have to do it yet well
before example just look at this line
right if I look at this line using what
I've just kind of established right now
I can work out dy on to defeat off
fairly easily right like that B is just
a constant
okay so I'll write that in a second and
in the same way I'll leave the other
piece of chain rule which is D feed up
on D X now that's a little awkward but
all I need to do is find out what DX OD
theater is which I can do and then I
just need to take the reciprocal does
that make sense okay so let's just go
ahead and evaluate do you want to defeat
it that was the easier woman right we
just established that when you
differentiate sine he turns into cosine
okay and then there's the be hanging out
the front right so the simple derivative
dy D theta is just B cos theta the times
okay then when I go to differentiate the
next thing because X is the subject I
can only do TX on D theta first I'd have
to reverse the whole equation get the
inverse function and so on which I'm not
equipped to do yet so what is DX of D
here cause it turns it to negative sine
you see that right
so therefore this a cos theta will
differentiate into minus a sine theta
okay so keep in mind that's multiplying
by now what they're super calm down
ahead they're reciprocal so I'm gonna
get one on - a sine theta I know it's
not customary to write negative signs on
the denominator but you see why I'm
doing that
trying to indicate this is a reciprocal
of a whole thing right that minus sign
isn't going to go up we're talking too
much simplified email okay which only
takes my whole life really let's just
tidy it ever so slightly - because the
feed on the top and what tell you now I
could I suppose write this as minus B or
a times copied up in theory I could do
that however I certainly am NOT going to
do that just yet because the question I
want to ask is why did I do this
where was this going rainy I want to
bring it because it was going to factor
into here remember I'm gonna put the
point together with the gradient using
point rating form and then I'm gonna get
the equation of this tangent but look
look look at this point do you see that
the pieces in here are very likely to
simplify with the pieces here does that
make sense
so even though I could write it as hot I
ain't nothing out of it I'm gonna have
to turn it back into cosines and sines
when I wanted to play together with this
let's do it the equation of the tangent
at page
is simply Y minus y1 and X minus x1 okay
and I know what all of this piece is up
one two three okay so let's just quick
and get that down
y-
okay now you look at that I'm gonna give
you a minute to get a bit of a head
start on me clearly there's some
simplifying that can happen here okay
how much typifying can be done why don't
you give it a shot and if you could give
me the answer in well I was gonna say
general form
yeah general form will do it and then
I'll show you the general that the form
is usually used it's not general form
but it's not very far from it so give it
a go see how far you get simplified out
I should point out the way that I went
about it okay now I asked it for it I
asked for it in general form okay so I
have skipped a line here but it's a
fairly boring line I've multiplied
through by a sine of theta to get rid of
that fraction and then I expanded the
right hand side as most of you have done
if you gather every single thing on the
left hand side which is the way general
form E is then you get this kind of mess
okay but clearly there's something you
know there's a trigonometric identity
that's going to help you namely very
good so if you factor out here that
minus a B right you're going to get sine
squared plus cos squared which is always
equal to one for every value of theta so
therefore this really is just - maybe
okay
now being that when we have a look at
this thing if I could write minus a B
over here that we find but if I put the
a B on the right hand side it's not
general form anymore the reason why this
ends up being nice is because the next
line I'm going to write is join to draw
a parallel with something I've already
seen before namely if I give up now
divide everything to you by a bit to by
the law okay it's gonna look like this
do you see this is what I would get if I
divided through by a B now that that
takes us away from general form however
the reason why this looks nice to me is
because look at how many parallels this
has to this to the standard formative
element of an ellipse right everything's
equal to one
your X's are your age let's start you've
got your wise your beads match top which
i think is generally speaking much
better than this which is actually a
reversal but where the pairs are
supposed to be happening the X and V cos
theta and then a they're all meant to
gather together you see now right and
the Y and the same thing and the B they
are all meant to be gathered together so
I think this is kind of a nice and
winner yeah well I won't actually just
prove it I'm just going to say that so
that right this is not quite the same as
the equation for the normal way what I
have to change how I would have to go
back up to change this working to get
them all yeah this derivative is not for
what I want I actually want the negative
reciprocal of this which would be a sine
theta on because they don't write and
that would come in here if you go ahead
and you try to out this is the equation
of the tangent the equation of the
normal will look like this
it's not nearly as neat as the equation
of the tangent which is unsurprising yet
this difference of squares we live over
here but you still have that a X and cos
theta married up together and the B and
the Y and the sine theta also together
so it's still got the nice symmetry to
it now
what did we do to establish this we
created needed to become a bit of a
swifty on this guy right we'll prove
this properly later on okay but once you
doing that the rest of it falls out very
very simply what do we need to know we
need to do a chain rule and then we
needed to know Y minus y1 equals M
outside of X minus x1 like you've
learned a long time ago
so parametric the parametric equations
sort of made this very very simple
ok it's lunch